unser Erspartes können wir natürlich am
besten dadurch retten indem wir als
Einzelne nicht auf irgendetwas fetten
sondern das machen was früher schon die
bildbörsenomi uns geraten hat breit
gestreut nie bereut das gilt eben nicht
nur für irgendwelche Aktien sondern das
gilt eben auch für Einlagen natürlich
wir haben die staatliche
Einlagensicherung in Deutschland wir
haben Sicherungssysteme der Sparkasse
der Volksbanken der Privatbanken die
oben drauf kommen keiner muss jetzt hier
Angst um sein Geld haben das ist ganz
wichtig aber man möchte ja auch immer
handlungsfähig sein egal was passiert
insofern warum nicht ein zweit und ein
drittkonto das ist das was man praktisch
tun kann als einzelner und vielleicht
auch nicht das Geld für ein Schnaps mehr
sind gleich irgendwo in der
Weltgeschichte in andere Länder
herumschicken auch eine kurzfristige
Bundesanleihe bietet 2,8 bis 3% in
diesen Zeiten und da hat man
zumindestens soliden Schulden aber wenn
der die Geräte macht dann ist viel
schief gegangen
testen was der Regulator natürlich tun
muss er muss klar machen dass er
Fehlverhalten und Spekulationen nicht
duldet wir brauchen eine starke
Regulierung in den USA weil das mit
eines der Probleme dass Donald Trump den
Dodge Frank Act mit dem Obama auf die
Finanzkrise reagiert hatte für solche
Regionalbanken zurückgefahren hat und
solche Regionalbanken können dann eben
sehr groß werden wie wir im Silicon
Valley gesehen haben wenn sie in
offensives Geschäftsmodell haben und wir
brauchen aber auch natürlich klare
Sanktionen wenn Fehlverhalten vorliegt
da kann ja nur hoffen dass die
Amerikaner ein klares Signal geben es
gibt Berichte darüber dass die Vorstände
der Silicon Valley Bank noch kurz vor
diesem Kollaps Aktien verkauft haben
dass sie Boni verteilt haben also diese
Boni die gehören natürlich ein kassiert
die Erlöser aus den Aktienverkäufen
gehören einkassierte Leute gehören an
den Pranger gestellt weil auch da haben
wir wieder das Thema
müssen alle das Gefühl haben dass
diejenigen die gegen die Regeln
verstoßen bestraft werden weil sonst
bricht uns das zusammen weil Banking
genau wie die Marktwirtschaft lebt vom
Vertrauen und vom Mitmachen und es gibt
offenbar so höre ich raus in einigen
Banken einfach zu schlechtes Management
und zu wenig auf sich zu wenig Kontrolle
also ich denke wir haben in Europa eine
ganze Menge aus der Finanzkrise gelernt
natürlich könnte dann der einen oder
anderen auf sich Stelle die Aufsicht der
deutlich stärker sein wir in Deutschland
haben halt wirklich auch das Glück mit
diesen drei Säulen Bankensystem mit
Sparkassen mit Genossenschaften mit
privaten
Geschäftsbanken die jeweils voneinander
unabhängig sind ja in den USA haben wir
sehr sehr viele Regionalbanken von denen
übrigens immer auch relativ viele mal
wieder pleite gegangen sind das war halt
alles sehr zersplittert aber wenn dann
so eine Regionalbank plötzlich kommt und
zu einer richtigen macht wird aber immer
noch die Regionalbanken Regulierung
nutzt dann haben wir natürlich ein
Problem
das haben wir jetzt gesehen und das
ganze kombiniert natürlich mit einem
Risikomanagement was neu ja so ein
bisschen wild west oder so ein bisschen
Lachs war na also man hat ja in einem
Silicon Valley das Geld der einlege was
im Wesentlichen ja
Technologieunternehmen waren keine
kleinen Sparer weil man irgendwas damit
machen musste als Bank irgendwann man
konnte keinen sinnvolles Geschäft und
machen also in langfristige
Staatsanleihen gelegt und die haben
einen Wert verloren durch den
Zinsanstieg und das ist alles nicht so
schlimm so lange nicht irgendwann die
Leute ans Geld wollen
wurde richtig falsch gemanagt da wurden
noch Bonis in letzter Sekunde schnell
noch ausgezeichnet wurde
da muss man auch sagen also da ist auch
wirklich die Frage irgendwie wird es nie
irgendwo auf strafrechtlich relevant ist
weil er ist ja nicht mehr falsch das ist
dann das ist dann Vorsatz also ähm
President beiden hat ja sehr klar
erklärt dass es in der bei der
keine Rettung der Bank gibt das heißt
also es werden nicht die Aktionäre und
es werden nicht die Gläubiger der Bank
gerettet sondern es werden die Einleger
der Bank gerettet
dann hat er gesagt that's capital ist in
works ja es ist richtig so funktioniert
aber es funktioniert auch so dass
diejenigen die sich nicht an die Regeln
halten mit aller Härte dann entsprechend
bestraft werden müssen das bedeutet auch
Herr Platz 2018
dagegen gesteuert muss man vielleicht
auch manchmal die Banken in die Misere
laufen lassen nicht eingreifen damit sie
lernen
nein das ist ja sehr schnell auch
gefährlich für die Gesellschaft für uns
alle das haben wir ja zur Zeit der
Finanzkrise auch bemerkt ich bin genau
der Meinung wie Sie dass wir auch die
Regeln hier in Europa und in Deutschland
überprüfen sollten wenn sich mal
anschaut jemand der einen Kredit
bekommen möchte von einer Bank der muss
heute relativ viel Eigenkapital
mitbringen meistens 20 30 Prozent
mindestens und die Banken selber
brauchen für ihre Geschäfte nur ganz
ganz wenig Eigenkapital das stimmt doch
irgendwas nicht und daher müssten wir
auch hier die Regeln straffen und
brauchen dringend auch eine Diskussion
darüber damit uns nicht so etwas blüht
was wir vor 14 15 Jahren hier in
Deutschland erlebt haben denn am Ende
gibt ja immer ein der dann alles
bezahlen muss und das war in der
Vergangenheit am meistens der
Steuerzahler genau der Staat und dann
der Steuerzahler wir wie sich das
vorherige was könnte man da verändern
also es muss es muss ganz klar diese
Trennlinie gezogen werden im
Zweifelsfall gibt es eine Garantie für
die Spareinlagen da muss man sicherlich
auch den einen oder anderen in die
Mithaftung nehmen also warum die
amerikanische Einlagensicherung jetzt
jedem Unternehmen das sagen ja teilweise
100% seiner Mittel bei einer einzigen
Bank angelegt hat also auch so
Risikomanagement bei yupid Betrieben hat
in dieser
wolkigen Startup Welt das zu 100% wieder
ersetzt das weiß ich nicht also rokus
sondern börsennotierte Streaming
Plattform hat von 460 Millionen Dollar
126 Millionen bei der Bank gehabt naja
also die gehen jetzt nicht pleite wenn
sie nicht die wollen 126 drücken also da
müsste man auch schon da Eigentum
verpflichtet zur Diversifikation zur
Streuung die müsste man zumindest einmal
auch ein bisschen in die Mithaftung
nehmen aber ansonsten ganz klar wir
müssen dann um auch zukünftige Krisen zu
verhindern und das hat beiden mit dieser
schnellen Reaktion deutlich gemacht
zeigt übrigens auch wie eng die Sache
wahrscheinlich war es werden Einleger
gerettet in dem Umfang dass sie nicht
ein existenziellen Schaden daraus
erlassen
ich habe gerade gesagt jetzt wackelt die
Credit Suisse und viele denken ich hebe
lieber alles ganz schnell ab ab in den
Sparstrumpf wieder zurück und das
Kopfkissen hauptsache ich habe nicht
mehr irgendwo auf der Bank was liegen
was sagen sie zu sehr also Situationen
wenn das wenn das alle machen dann ist
das genauso wie die nächste Finanzkrise
existiert wir hatten so eine Situation
2018 sind an einem Wochenende als ich
abzeichnete das ist Montag eventuell aus
Grund der Angst der Leute vor dieser
Finanzkrise an solchen Bank Run geben
könnte sind per Steinbrück und Frau
Merkels Bundeskanzlerin vor die Presse
gegangen gesagt werden garantieren die
Sicherheit ihrer spracheinlagen das war
nur ein narrativ das war ja keine wirk
Garantie zu sagen wenn das Parlament für
entscheiden müssen braucht man nicht
besser hat gereicht um das Vertrauen
wieder hinarbeiten wieder herzustellen
ja und das ist das ist wichtig dass auch
das alle wissen wir haben ja jetzt keine
Situation wie niemand es kippeln hier
keine deutschen Banken und dass die
Quelle Swiss kippelt ist die Folge von
jahrelang wirklich Jahre lang
Missmanagement und das kündigt sich ja
nun schon seit ein paar Monaten an und
wir müssen ja eigentlich davon ausgehen
mit dem vorlaufen das Notenbanken und
Regierungen da irgendwelche Notfallpläne
in der Tasche haben nur wenn die Frage
kommt ähm rutschen wir jetzt auch in
eine Finanzkrise es wäre natürlich
absolut töricht zu sagen nein weil wir
wissen ja gar nicht was da verborgen ist
was da irgendwo wollen gerade bei der
Kredits in irgendwelchen Derivate
Bilanzen oder sonst was noch drin steckt
vielleicht wissen sie selber auch noch
gar nicht so genau sie haben ja gerade
bei ihrem Jahresabschluss gesagt na dann
müssen wir noch mal ein bisschen
nachrechnen wir uns noch nicht so oder
damit rauszugehen aber wichtig ist auch
hier wieder es geht um das Vertrauen der
Kreislauf muss am Laufen gehalten werden
die Banken müssen sich untereinander
Vertrauen damit sie im
Interbankengeschäft zumindest overnight
Geschäfte dann machen können und
natürlich auch die Menschen müssen den
Banken vertrauen dass dieses Thema
sicher sind die Systeme sind sicher denn
das Vertrauen da ist und das heißt aber
auch dass man sich als Teil dieses
Systems fühlt manche Menschen haben aber
vielleicht auch den Eindruck ist regiert
auf die Gier Herr Körner geht ihnen das
so als ich da was verändert in unserer
Gesellschaft das vielleicht der ein oder
andere auch gieriger geworden ist
ja tatsächlich ich habe schon den
Eindruck kann ich das nur wieder
kovi sagen das ist ja das beste Beispiel
für mich nämlich die Profiteure der
Pandemie und es ist nichts anderes als
Puri Gier ja also nicht ich habe zuvor
angesprochen wenn Impfärzte ihre
beziehungsweise ihre Tätigkeit in den
Krankenhäusern und so einfach lassen und
Urlaub nehmen damit man in der
Impfzentrum geht dann unterstelle ich
jetzt einfach bei den meisten dass das
nicht passiert weil sie sagen wir müssen
jetzt unbedingt die
Pandemie beenden sondern ganz einfach
weil das Geld im Hintergrund steht
nämlich der Stundenlohn und den kenne
ich sehr wohl und da würden sie jetzt
alle hier blass werden wenn ich das
erzählen würde was man da pro Stunde
bekommt also
zum Beispiel mir hat man in der Stunde
220 Euro angeboten zu impfen an sondern
Feiertagen mehr und jetzt rechnen Sie
das mal aus wenn Sie das täglich machen
und es vielleicht mal für zwei Wochen
dann haben sie ein nettes sümchen
beieinander das gleiche gilt für die
Testzentren die Testzentren haben sich
unter also garantiert einige dumm und
dämlich verdient um das mal so zu sagen
und das ganze narrativ der Angst wurde
aufrecht erhalten warum aber da keiner
interessiert dass das wieder abnimmt
weil man einfach nichts mehr verdient
und ich finde schon ja die hier
insgesamt hat zugenommen aber das kann
man ja auch weiter ausdehnen es ist
nicht nur die normale Bevölkerung sind
auch die Politiker zum Beispiel ich
denke jetzt mal bei unserem Bayern die
Masken Affäre ja dass man Masken
irgendwie
also ich finde es aber falsch dem
einzelnen hier vorzuwerfen wenn es doch
es war doch genau Zweck davon man wollte
möglichst schnell ist sie finden es
falsch aber es war doch der Sinn davon
möglichst schnell Masken zu bekommen und
möglichst schnell viele Leute zu impfen
dann hat doch haben doch die
Verantwortlichen die diese Anreize
gesetzt haben haben dafür gesorgt dass
es funktioniert und natürlich wenn man
mir 300 Euro die Stunde für was bietet
was ich kann und mache überlege ich mir
das natürlich auch sofort es zu tun das
ist doch keine gear das ist doch ganz
normal das Verhalten gewesen
ich sehe das als anders sich einfach
meinem ärztlichen Gewissen und meiner
Überzeugung folgen und das hoffe ich
dass das vielleicht für andere
Berufsgruppen auch noch gilt sie sehen
also liebe ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer wir
landen ganz schnell auf wieder bei dem
Thema Corona gleich jetzt hier aber nach
einer kurzen Pause weiter mit dem
deutschen vielleicht liebsten Thema das
Auto das ist aber in Gefahr bleiben Sie
dran bis gleich
wurden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um ihren
falls Sie